today on the Matt Walsh show we are told
that the shutdowns are worth it because
they're allegedly saving lives in fact
we've been told that even if the
shutdowns save just one life that would
be enough to justify the destruction of
the economy well on that note I've been
thinking about it and you know it occurs
to me that there's one type of business
just one type of business that we could
shut down permanently and save a million
lives a year just by shutting down this
one type of business so if you are in
favor of shutdowns to save lives
then you should agree with me on this
point we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the governor of New
Jersey admitting that he quote didn't
think about the Bill of Rights when he
was crafting his state home order which
is of course not a surprise we are to
knew that but to hear him say it out
loud is maybe a little bit surprising
and in our daily cancellation we will
examine the idea that only white people
can be racist this is what kids are
taught in school these days and
especially in college but events in
China would seem to very much contradict
that claim so we'll talk about that also
but first a word from our friends over
at zip recruiter and I want to begin
just by giving a thank you to zip
recruiter and all the sponsors of this
show it's a very difficult time for all
companies for everybody in general and
so that's why I want to especially thank
the sponsors of this show and of all of
our advertising partners at the Daily
wire who are helping to keep us going
through this time now zip recruiter is
one of our longest standing advertiser
partners and we're really proud to work
with them they what the service they
provide is indispensable especially at a
time like this today they wanted to do
something a little bit different than
the type of ad you're used to hearing so
here's a message from our sponsor at zip
recruiter to you it says right now we
cannot be overwhelmed we have to work to
get to keep our loved ones safe and
protect our communities we have to work
to stay strong to stay connected to stay
focused we have to work to inspire to
innovate to build new solutions but for
all this to work we have to work
together at zip recruiter we connect
employers and people every day but today
is different we are partnering with
first responders government officials
the medical community the innovators and
the manufacturing transportation and
foodist distribution industries to make
sure that we are finding the right
people for the right jobs right now
let's work together zip recruiter
dot-com / work together is where you
want to go okay a a common retorts to
conservatives who advocate for opening
up the economy is that we are betraying
our pro-life principles I'm sure you've
heard this this charge is and and it's
clearly absurd for a number of reasons
first of all one of our primary
arguments is that shutting down society
is probably not the most effective way
of saving lives many people are still
dying of the virus even during the
shutdown many will likely die once the
shutdown is lifted and even the most
ardent supporter of shutdowns must must
agree that we have to lift the shutdowns
eventually I mean eventually we have to
go back to our lives and the virus is
still going to be there when we go back
to our lives so we may not even be
saving any lives at all when all is said
and done and on top of that toll we now
have to add to it the lives that are
destroyed ruined ended in some cases by
the collapse of the economy all told you
know it is reasonable to worry that the
cost in human death and suffering will
be greater because of the shutdown that
it would have been had we not shut down
and had we adopted preventive measures
while still allowing the economy to
continue now you may disagree with that
argument okay but it's obviously not an
argument that denies the value of human
life that's not what the argument is
doing the argument is saying that human
life is extraordinarily valuable
infinitely valuable but our method right
now protecting human life is not a good
method here's a better one that's the
argument okay also nobody who criticizes
the strategy of willfully plunging the
nation into a great depression is
suggesting that the elderly and others
who are most vulnerable to the virus
should be directly killed okay none of
us are saying that this is not like a
eugenics argument we're merely
suggesting that there are other and
better ways of protecting those
populations and that the enormous cost
of our current method is far too high in
the payoff is far too uncertain
now by contrast advocates of abortion
support the direct and purposeful
killing of vulnerable people at the
earliest stages of life that is a very
different sort of position to take even
even if okay even if the anti shut down
people were to argue that the elderly
aren't worth protecting and we shouldn't
bother protecting them which which that
is most emphatically not what we're
arguing but what I'm saying is even if
we took that stance that stance would be
would look positively Gandhian in
comparison to those who openly celebrate
and advocate the medical execution of
infants which brings us to an important
point the flip side of the erroneous you
know you anti shut down people are
contradicting you're pro-life views
accusation is that a great many of the
pro shut down people actually are
contradicting their pro-abortion views
and asses as I've explained it is
possible for a reasonable person to
affirm the inherent value of human life
while also arguing that the shut downs
are unwise that is possible to do it's
very reasonable indeed a reasonable
person can argue that that that you know
it's it's the inherent value of human
life is the reason why we should not
have the shutdown's so it's not just
that you know in spite of that but it's
because of that that we shouldn't have
the shelves that is it that's a
reasonable argument you don't have again
you don't have to agree but it's a
reasonable argument but there's the
other side of that and what I can't see
on the other hand is how a person can
argue that it is just and proper to
intentionally kill a million human lives
every single year for the sake of
preserving the lifestyle of the parents
and then also argue that we must destroy
the lifestyles and livelihoods of
millions of people in order to preserve
human life so there seems to be a
logical disconnect there the latter
argument can only potentially make sense
if human life has inherent value while
the former argument could only
potentially make sense of human life has
and conditional value that is not
inherent value so which is it the pro
shutdown camp declares that every life
has value every life is worth saving I
agree with them but the odd thing is
that so many of them don't really agree
with them they don't appear to have a
coherent perspective on human life and
its value and that's one of the reasons
why this debate has been so fruitless
and doesn't go anywhere because we don't
we it we don't have an agreement on the
inherent value of human life and there
are people who are who are making claims
as if they believe that that human life
has inherent value when in fact they
don't believe that and that's how we end
up in this morbidly ironic situation
where a suit where we're a society that
kills a million babies a year for
convenience has shut itself down to
prevent the elderly from dying
if there's any principle here that can
be found it would see that the principle
is that adult life is more valuable and
more worthy of protection than the lives
of children which of course is
incoherent not to mention backwards and
and evil all life has value but a
healthy society I would say is it should
be far more willing to accept the death
of adults than the death of children
which isn't to say that we shouldn't do
anything to protect adults I'm not
saying that but adults must die
eventually after all children should not
least of all should they die by our own
hands which is what's happening a
properly ordered and healthy society
would see the death of an adult as a
tragedy which it is but the death of a
child it would see as something so
unspeakable that the word tragedy
doesn't even cover it we seem to have
flipped those things around flipped it
on its head and that doesn't
sense to me but look perhaps I'm being
too cynical I have to leave open the
possibility that all the pro-abortion
people who are now applauding the
ruination of our economy because even a
sacrifice as extraordinary as that is
worth it to save just one life
supposedly they say maybe all these
people have experienced a dramatic
change of heart you know maybe this is
not hypocrisy or inconsistency but it's
a sign that a new leaf has been turned
in our culture maybe these people have
discovered within themselves for the
first time a real passion for defending
the Worth and dignity of human life in
that case you know I welcome them to the
pro-life team welcome aboard
glad to have you and I would just like
to suggest that if we're pursuing a
policy of shutdowns to save lives we
only really need to close one type of
business it's it's it's the one type of
business that kills a million babies a
year in this country now we can argue
about the other shutdowns we can argue
about the the wisdom of the other
shutdowns and whether or not we should
be shutting down other businesses like
restaurants and and retail shops and so
on but anybody who really wants to
protect human life should agree that
that that this is the best place to
start that this at least is one type of
business abortion clinics that we should
certainly shut down and there is no
doubt that we could save many many lives
just by doing that so I'm glad we could
come to this understanding now let's
move on to headlines number one and
thousands of people in Michigan the
Michigan Michigan doors what is it
Michigan Heights Michigan ease but
anyway thousands of them showed up at
the State Capitol yesterday to protest
the onerous tyrannical orders coming
from the the emperor of Michigan Emperor
Whitmer and first of all these Patriots
deserve to be applauded for standing up
and I hope this is the start of a trend
it's just very beautiful it's a
beautiful thing to see
meanwhile the Emperor herself appeared
on NBC to justify her policies and she
explains I'm not making this up I'll
play you the clip she explained that
it's snowing in Michigan anyway and so
you don't really need
your liberties because it's snowing
watch this we just had snow I've got
snow on the ground here in Michigan
right now in Lansing we're expecting you
know up to 30 inches in the Upper
Peninsula the fact that we're cracking
down on people traveling between homes
or planting or landscaping or golfing
really for a couple more weeks isn't
going to meaningfully impact people's
ability to do it because the snow will
do that in and of itself we're cracking
down on people planting that's actually
what she said think about that cracking
down on people planting but that's okay
because it's snowing so you can't do
this stuff anyway which of course raises
a question well it raises many questions
one of which is this if you're saying
that nobody can do these things anyway
then why are you banning them what's the
point of saying you know this you're
forbidden from doing this but you can't
do this anyway so you shouldn't worry
about the fact that you're forbidden
from doing it well then why are you
bothering different bid them from doing
it of course in reality you still can do
all of those things for example you
could still plant even in Michigan you
can still buy seeds and plant them you
just you do it indoors we have plants
growing inside our house right now many
people do even though I don't live in
Michigan but so that it's it's not true
first of all but even if it even if it
was the excuse makes no sense
number two the UH the new unemployment
numbers have been released five million
Americans applied for unemployment last
week that makes the total number of
unemployed since this bit census all
began about twenty two million or
fifteen percent of the labor force we
have officially lost fifteen percent of
the labor force in a month which it goes
without saying is unprecedent it has
never happened before so we are on
entirely on we are in uncharted waters
at the moment but really these numbers
we have to we have to remember I've keep
reminding people when we talk about this
that these numbers are almost
meaningless almost meaningless not
because they don't matter but because
the actual numbers are much much higher
than this okay
all this tells us is the number of
people who successfully applied for
unemployment it does not include the
many millions of people who tried to
apply and could get through because the
systems were down and also all the
people who don't qualify for
unemployment in the first place even
though they're worth they are without a
job right now so we talked about 22
million that is I mean not even the tip
of the iceberg that is just that that's
a that's a minimal starting point but we
have to remember that it's much higher
than that and this is also it's
important to note because I've seen some
people this morning all but celebrating
because well five million people filed
for unemployment but that's down from 6
million the week before so it's only 5
million only 5 million people which even
if it was just the 5 million there's
there's nothing to celebrate there
that's not an improvement that is 5
million additional people who don't have
jobs now but in fact it's a lot more
than 5 million that's the point number 3
Joe Biden was on Morning Joe today and
offered a very touching story well I
think it was a touching story I couldn't
really tell but maybe let's see if you
can make heads or tails of this i sat
with a guy yesterday on on a telephone
and he's telling me he said I don't
always said look III worked through the
hospital
and he said then I got I got myself in a
position where I got the virus so they
quarantine me and and they put me in the
hospital I made it out and so I'm out
but they don't want me with my family
I'm on the third floor I spent 15
minutes in a phone with him saying he
said I have a three-year-old and a
four-year-old they come in the door
outside and they just knock on the door
say daddy daddy can I see you daddy can
I see you daddy so we spent time going
through it I used to do with my kids
they're little and I couldn't see them
and we'd play games I said naca make up
a game knocking knock on the door and
say this is you know the practical
things the guys scared to death and he
said she's worried about his children
he's worried about us what I mean these
are practical things so the president
talks about this like okay it's gonna be
okay we're gonna open two
we're gonna do this I mean it's just I
must tell you it drives me crazy I don't
know what he doesn't understand about
people's fears so I'm not sure I I don't
know exactly what's going on there it
seems like he was starting to say that
he what was he he was in quarantine or
something once when he was with when he
was a parent of young children or I
don't know exactly I was kind of
distracted because I was more paying
attention to his wife sitting next to
him and you could see the expression on
her face where she was she was sort of
thinking like where is this going Joe
where is this going
it's actually a look I'm very familiar
with because my I get that for my wife
sometimes but I start saying something
publicly and she got has this look like
okay where is this headed alright let's
let's stay on the theme of bizarre cable
news interviews because these are these
are fun here's the Emperor of New Jersey
Emperor Murphy on Tucker Carlson last
night he made a rather stunning
admission watch you made that decision
and as I noted before 15 congregants at
a synagogue in New Jersey were arrested
and charged for being in a synagogue
together now the Bill of Rights as you
well know protects Americans right in
shrines their right to practice their
religion as they see fit and to
congregate together to assemble
peacefully by what authority did unify
the Bill of Rights in issuing this order
how do you have the power we were that
that's above my paygrade Tucker so I
wasn't I wasn't thinking of the Bill of
Rights when we did this we went to all
first of all we looked at the day like
it's a science and it says I wasn't
thinking about the Bill of Rights when I
did this that is a that's that's some
honesty right there I appreciate the
honesty
and of course I we already knew that
it's very clear that they're not
thinking about the Bill of Rights when
they come up with these shutdowns the
fact that he that he feels so safe in
saying that they isn't he's no problem
coming out and saying I wasn't think
about the Bill of Rights Bill of Rights
mill of Rights that should good
as though but it tells you exactly where
I mean for all the people who are still
denying that our our basic civil
liberties are being infringed upon you
know maybe just open your eyes and also
your ears listen to what these people
are saying they will tell you they are
all but telling us yes we are infringing
on your civil liberties we are doing it
they're basically announcing it as they
do it and yet you still have morons out
there saying what are you talking about
our liberties aren't being infringed
upon he just said yeah I didn't think
about the Bill of Rights so it's not
relevant to what I'm doing just like
we've had cops saying you know First
Amendment is non-essential your rights
are suspended five finally doctor foul
she did an interview on snapchats
good luck America which is evidently a
thing reading now from the New York Post
it says toward the end of the tape
segment Falchi was asked if you're
swiping on a dating app like tinder or
Bumble or Grindr and you match with
someone that you think is hot and you're
just kind of like maybe it's fine if
this one stranger comes over what do you
say to that person
okay so we're asking dr. Falchi for
dating advice now which why not we
already we get economic advice from him
we get all kinds of advice doctor and
foul she is now our national guru who we
go to for advice on all topics because
he is an all-knowing all-seeing
omnipotent being and he replied you know
that's tough because that's what's
called relative risk then then he
dropped the bombshell if you're willing
to take a risk and you know everybody
has their own tolerance for risks you
could figure out if you want to meet
somebody and then he added if you want
to go a little bit more intimate well
then that's your choice regarding a risk
okay so first of all doctor foul Qi has
given you permission to have sexual
relations with strangers so he's given
you if you're going to him for
permission he's giving it to you because
as I said of course we go to doctor foul
chief or really anything you want to do
now you have to go to doctor Falchi
he'll tell you if you can do it or not
is this consistent with everything
he said no but you know we can't expect
him to be consistent that's that's no
he's he'll decide in the moment what's
what's the safest thing and what isn't
so we've got dr. Fauci saying yeah you
know if you want to have sex with a
stranger you go ahead and do that
meanwhile in some states like in
Michigan you're not allowed to have your
own family members over just to visit
for dinner so you can't have your
parents over for dinner but you can
invite we're told it's safe to invite a
stranger over to have sex that's makes a
lot of sense right now let's let's move
on to your daily cancellation but before
we do a note about The Daily wire
quarantine you know might not be any fun
but you know what is fun The Daily wire
deal I'm about to share with you when
you become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member then you will get not
one but two of the highly coveted
leftist here's Tumblr's rumor has it
that this tumblr completely eliminates
the threats of thirst if you fill it
with some sort of liquid and then drink
the liquid that is the not just rumor
but in fact that's a scientific fact
daily wire members get many amazing
benefits including of course the
magnificent the irreplaceable singular
leftist ears tumblr you also get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election insight op-eds from
ben shapiro as well Delabar members also
get to ask us questions during backstage
and our new all access to your allows
you to join in live online Q&A s with me
and the other hosts as well so there's a
ton of stuff you get and again that's to
leftist tiers tumblers not just one but
two when you become a daily wire insider
plus or all-access member ok today we're
canceling the people who claim that only
white people can be racist that whole
school of thought is officially
cancelled and just to be clear that is a
very real school of thought there are
people out there who not only believe
this but teach it's taught in schools
many left.this believe and will tell you
if you ask them
that racism is power plus prejudice
that's the equation and only white
people have power allegedly so only they
can be racist and this holds true
doesn't matter I mean even when Barack
Obama was president according to this
formulation he had no power he was the
most powerful man in the world but he
actually had no power because of the
color of his skin and so you could be
racist to him but he couldn't be racist
to you even though he's the President
and you're just a peon right now of
course all you have to do really is open
your eyes and look around and you can
see that this is not the case and it's
totally insane in fact the very claim
that racism is exclusive to white people
is itself racism against White's so it's
not hard to disprove but here's one
thing one example that will be
especially hard I think for the only
whites are racist crowd to navigate
around and that is China since you know
dumping on China is the popular thing to
do right now and for good reason they
certainly deserve it let's uh let's add
this into the mix a McDonald's in China
actually recently tried to ban black
people from entering the restaurant okay
here's the BBC report about the incident
it says McDonald's and China has
apologized after a branch in the
industrial city of Guangzhou barred
black people from entering a video
shared on social media showed a notice
that read we've been informed that from
now on black people are not allowed to
enter the restaurant McDonald's said
that when it found out about the notice
it temporarily closed the restaurant
tensions have been running high between
Africans and local people in the city
last week hundreds of Africans in
Guangzhou were evicted from hotels and
apartments after online rumors that
coronavirus was spreading among African
people Guangzhou is a hub for Africa
African traders buying and selling goods
in his home - one of China's largest
African communities and so on it goes up
there yeah this is not very surprising
there have been many reports of anti
black bigotry and violence in response
to the pandemic in China which of course
makes no sense on a number of levels
starting with the fact that the virus
started
China and because of China not in Africa
but then bigotry of course never really
does make sense but this is all in the
context of Chinese culture which has a
huge problem with racism especially anti
black racism but but also just racism in
general and Chinese culture is very
racist and this extends beyond China
anti black bigotry is all over East Asia
South Asia India you know anyone who has
any experience with any of these
countries knows this and will tell you
it's the very large elephant in the room
whenever somebody is preaching about the
unique evils of white racism
you've got Asia you know the very big
elephant in the room or on the globe
anyway where racism is extremely common
and socially acceptable here's another
example this is a a Chinese ad for a
laundry detergent now I want you to
watch this and think what kind of
culture produces an ad like this watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now for anybody listening on iTunes or
SoundCloud or something you couldn't see
the ad just to describe it to you that
was an ad Chinese detergent and in the
ad a black man is stuffed into a washing
machine and when he's lifted out he's
now Chinese okay now can you imagine an
ad like that in this country can you
imagine like Tide detergent putting out
an ad like that no you can't it could
never happen I mean that could only
exist in a country where racism is open
and acceptable a country like China and
it's not just China by the way it's not
just Asia either I mean the fact is
while the left tries to make the claim
that the u.s. is is somehow the most
racist country on Earth the truth is
probably exactly the opposite of that
now racism exists in this country
obviously like it exists everywhere and
always will but it's not acceptable and
being openly racist will get you
ostracized in this country and this is
also in a country with more ethnic
diversity than any other so it's not
like it's easy for us not to be racist
because we're all the same race anyway
now it's not something like that it's
we've got a whole bunch of ethnicities
and races living in this country and we
do a better job of with that and of
promoting diversity and of you know
getting rid of racism then any other
country does but you know
you're not gonna hear that from from the
left and and and you need a they've got
this very simplistic narrative and it's
really easy it's convenient white people
are evil white people are racist and so
they have no choice but to ignore you
know the racism that happens all across
the world among you know billions of
people all across the world alright
let's go to emails and if you become a
daily Y remember you can always email
the show through the mailbag this is
from teenis is the name that's with a t
teenis I don't know if that's his god if
that's his Christian name or not not
sure but he says dear Matt I actually
don't mind the whole state enforce
mandatory mask-wearing because they're
just trying to keep us safe and healthy
but I don't wear one myself because they
get in the way of my cigarettes I
appreciate that teenis
and you know what I also think that I've
said before which we you know I think we
can reopen the economy and I think it
makes sense at least in certain contexts
and in certain industries for there to
be masks and you know even if you want
to have a laws and policies and
individual places that require masks I
don't I don't necessarily see a problem
with that as long as it's not overly
onerous and as long as it makes sense
now requiring somebody to have a mask
when they're walking down the street
that doesn't make sense
but in certain industries it might make
sense I mean the restaurant industry for
example maybe so I don't have I don't
really have a problem with that but
one of the the issues that I have one of
the big issues is that only a month ago
the government was telling us don't wear
masks not just telling us not to but
scolding us for wearing them and now
they want to mandate them let's go to
this is from sp it says I'm a
homeschooling parent going on two years
do you think there's gonna be a backlash
against homeschooling due to all the
parents who have been currently forced
in homeschooling because of covin 19
school closures I recognize this issue
is already under attack under normal
circumstances and fear possible long
term policy repercussions well there's
you talk about a backlash from
government policy or just from the from
society in general I think no I think I
think looking on the bright side of it I
think that there are gonna be people who
have been homeschooling during this and
discover that you know it's not as hard
as they thought maybe they actually
enjoy it I've actually heard from quite
a few parents who have told me this that
they've been forced into becoming
homeschool parents as all parents have
across the country and they said they
they actually enjoy it and it's made
them rethink the idea of homeschooling
so I think you might probably would be
the opposite you're going to see an
increase in homeschooling it's gonna
become more popular now will the
government try to counteract that when
they see people they see parents pulling
kids out of government schools is the
government gonna try to tamp down on
that to try to get there to try to get
the their subjects back into the school
classrooms I think that's a very real
possibility from Chuck says hi Matt
you've been spending a lot of time
criticizing the government which I
understand but I haven't heard you
grapple with what the Bible says about
this to remind you then he quotes let
everyone be subject to the governing
authorities for there is no authority
except that which God has established
the authorities that exist have been
established by God consequently whoever
rebels against the authority is
rebelling against what God has
instituted and those who do so will be
bring to judgment on themselves isn't it
our responsibility
he continues to listen to respect and
yes obey these shut down orders even if
we disagree with them isn't that what
the Bible says all right well and that's
it's 13 that he's quoting there of
course so Chuck what I would say is I
think there are two ways to interpret
that passage that you just quoted one is
to interpret it broadly universally very
literally and say it applies across the
board and basically every government
isn't suitable instituted by God every
government has the authority of has
divine authority in effect and so it is
always wrong to disobey and to rebel
against the government you know you
could interpret it that way all right
the other way of interpreting it is to
understand it as something with
limitations and and to understand that
the government can actually lose its
god-given Authority and its moral
authority and by losing its moral
authority it loses its god-given
Authority so those are the two ways
generally speaking of interpreting it
now the problem yes if you interpret it
the first way then that would obviously
apply to all these shutdowns and all we
could really do is now we could complain
I guess but we have to go along with it
you certainly can't defy it and I guess
really we shouldn't even complain about
it or speak out against it because we
have to believe that this you know these
the this is god-given Authority and
they're doing what's best for us and so
just cooperate and go along if you're
gonna go with the first interpretation
yes that is how you would approach the
shutdown's problem though I think is
rather obvious because if that's the
case then that would apply that would
have applied to the Nazi government in
journey' Germany in the 1940s and we
would have to say we would have to say
that the Nazi government was instituted
by God it had divine authority and
anyone who disobeyed or rebelled against
you know the Jews in the ghettos who
rebelled against the government they
were doing the wrong thing they were
doing something that was morally wrong
and that their responsibility was just
to get on the the train cars and go to
the concentration camp that's what you
would have to say if you're going with
that first interpretation you would also
have to say of course that
our this country was founded
illegitimately because this country was
founded on a rebellion against a
governing authority and that raises all
kinds of questions because if that's the
case then our government I guess is not
legitimate so does it have governing I
think by that interpretation maybe you
would say this government has no
authority whatsoever because it was
founded illegitimately by rebelling
against the authorities that it was
supposed to be subjected to so I think
this interpretation becomes just morally
obscene and illogical I think it's very
clear it's self-evident that for example
the Nazi government had no god-given
authority whatsoever and that to rebel
against it was not only acceptable but
was the morally right thing to do and
was courageous and it's what God wanted
so that that
just Macbeth argument you can but I
think your your your interpreting a
biblical passage in a way that is
morally obscene and I think we have to
avoid doing that which leaves us with
the second interpretation which is there
are some limitations on that and the
government can lose its god-given
Authority well another example our
government says that it's okay to kill
babies like we talked about the
beginning of show a million babies a
year are killed legally and according to
the interpretation you're going with
here it would seem that you know we
can't really define a Torah Bell against
it and we just have to accept it because
the government says it's okay to kill
babies so therefore it is I don't
believe that and I'm believing for a
second there is an authority higher than
the government right now we know that
under normal circumstances the
government derives its authority from
God but that means that God is of course
above the government and the government
cannot overturn basic moral laws so I go
with the fact that there are limitations
on that Authority and then it becomes a
question of do these shutdowns exceed
those limitations and that's you know
that's a that's a question open for
debate I think it does and my answer is
yes I think it does because the
government itself is acting unlawfully
we know the way that our the way that
our system is set up the ultimate
supreme legal authority is not just the
opinion or the whim of a governor or a
bureaucrat or a senator or the president
the ultimate legal authorities of
Constitution United States and they are
defying that so they are acting
unlawfully and therefore forfeiting
their authority in my view but it's it's
an interesting discussion to have so I
thank you for the email thanks everybody
for watching and listening have a great
day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]